all right and we are live
fresh on that thursday
live campfire a little different you
know a little figure we come together
do something special obviously e is is
going away and uh we would like to sneak
something in but it's the last word
with lord cognito ibontis and thai guy
travis
we absolutely love that we're able to do
this so uh first what's going on with
you
e i'm happy that i was able to i didn't
think i'd be able to
yeah i'm podcast getting ready to set an
alarm for like 2 30 in the morning
and as a normal human being not a
vampire like you this is gonna be
i wake up early anyway like i'm used to
setting alarms at 4 30 4 50 because i go
teach classes at like 5 30 in the
morning
2 30 is just a whole different level of
bad so i have an early departure
for a flight covert test is done got the
negative result there
mostly done with packing getting all
that stuff kind of set up and everything
um but like what i will tell you
traveling right now internationally is
a bit of a hassle yeah because there's
an app for the country you got to fill
that stuff out there you got to scan in
your immigration form you got to get
that qr code you scan that into a
different app that you got to put in for
the airline that you're flying through
put your information in there scan in
your covet test take your picture of
your passport take your picture of this
and i'm just like anybody need anything
else i think you all have my life story
by now so i've been
prepping for travel since tuesday but it
is if we can just make it where we're
going i'm good our connection is in
miami which has me worried
because it's not the quietest airport
nor is you know florida it's the best
place right now
um it's an hour and 12 minutes
currently our gates are not that far
apart but that stuff moves all
throughout the day and so you're
basically like an hour away so
cross my fingers that the gate actually
stays there
uh because it's actually a pretty good
connection right now but yeah i'm just
basically prepping to fly
but we got two things major to talk
about the 12 we knew was gonna be meaty
and then yesterday it just exploded
um so we have to talk about that as well
so
before we get into that stuff though
travis man
got you on here in the middle of the day
don't let anybody at work know yeah but
uh you know secret sauce
yeah it's great man look what's happened
to this podcast where
on a thursday it we're on youtube
uh i'm here yeah we got crucible maps
announced i mean just like five teams
i'm gonna be i'm gonna i'm gonna be
known for
uh in your guys's uh community for for
being the harbinger of when the show
really went downhill i'd be like man
when that guy
got on youtube
beginning of the end really yeah you
guys you guys have like 18 months left
of the show and then
and then you know that's that's that's
all she wrote so
that's it it's a pretty good run we
could at least make it to 200 at that
point you know
yeah it's true we got to get to 301
though
we have to get the 301 on fire team yeah
well you guys will probably do that on
about august 20
well fourth or whenever i'm sure you
guys or 27.
or something you'll probably do with
that friday so
well yeah um cog what are you been up to
man
chilling man i played a paid a bit of
destiny i'm actually um
finishing i'm actually gonna get my
splicer title i
i didn't even realize how close i was to
it like
just not really playing playing
sporadically
you know what it is i was doing a lot of
um
farming for splicing web i really like
the spice weapons i'm a huge fan of
ignition code
huge fan of grid skipper almost becoming
one of my pve joints i'm liking my
i love the heating up perk with um right
now i'm using multi-kill clip
i have a multi-clip frenzy option
because of the expunge
farm where you get the the two thing so
what i was realizing
i was getting a lot of the challenges
done so now i just got to finish the
board i got two more spots at the bottom
for the 500 decrypted
and then it dude i will have the title
i'm like i can't believe i'm actually
going to have a title
and i played very very casually so yeah
like i
i've been pretty light on it as well and
i had to go get like
four champions in expunges and mine was
mine was the same thing it was a couple
boxes to check but it was a pretty
natural title
it's not like fate breaker not even
close i mean probably
nowhere near even anything on that one
but no the splicer title definitely is
not too bad
i have been playing grime this week
uh it's a little indie kind of 2d
souls-like um
and then off-stream i played a little
bit of elder souls which
i can't remember who said that i think
paul did because i was listening to dcp
and they were talking about it
eldest souls is like the epitome of um
seo yes because they have eldest for
elden rings
souls is in there and they just like
they combine all the words so if you
look up what you're bound to trip over
this game
that cracked me up when uh tessie said
that i forget where he said it though
and it's a fun little basically kind of
it's a
kind of top-down boss rush but it's got
a few it was kind of cool just a little
like not quite pixel art but it was
it was a fun little game just in this
little break i finished mass effect 2
which that was the big one so two is
done
um bigger hat better than one or oh is
this the question
i gotta finish all three before i really
give my vote but is it better than what
you're better than just doing this too
just doing based on what you played i
mean you may like one better don't feel
pressure
no i mean like you like one better you
stand on your screen and say you know
what you guys
i joined one better it was very
interesting to go through mass effect 2
being as so much of i did every loyalty
mission every
recruitment and then you get to what
this thing that you kind of get
introduced to in the beginning
and you're like okay how many more steps
are going to be after that
that was it like you had the cool moment
when you get there but so much of it was
building these characters now did i like
learning about the characters somewhere
better than others
but some of the missions were really
cool that you got to learn about some of
them weren't as much i did a couple
i didn't do as much of the dlc uh but
i've done
some questions question yeah um
so did you do all right did you do you
did lay up the shower broker
i did shadow broker yes i did that one
liar's not out there now
so okay cool question in reference to
squad mates you said you liked a lot of
the stories like the personal story
like yeah i mean it's the top give me
top top three
squad mates that you liked
um first let's start with their favorite
who was your f in mass effect 2
who was your favorite squad that you
felt that you had to have every mission
like you really enjoyed
playing with the character horror story
got them but thane was so
unique i mean thane was
really unique i just like lost like you
know the photographic memory how it
relives things the stuff that he went
through
obviously having to like deal with his
kid but didn't have to actually
kill him um all that so it was like i
went full paragon by the way in case
anybody was wondering
how my play through when it was full
paragon
romance liara and miranda i think mm-hmm
um
yeah yeah like i'm setting it up i'm
like well this one happened and it was
because of in mass effect 1 i did
romance liara
and then i'm going through this one and
it was
like just miranda was a kind of a very
obvious but really the only one that
ended up playing out i think
um trying to think of so thane was cool
garrus is always cool garrus is just
like a legit
kind of chill dude kind of a bit of a
badass but somewhat subdued in his own
little way he's just kind of a
a cool guy to have with you um yeah
grunt was actually a surprise i didn't
expect really first grad
okay no i mean no i mean grunt was just
a surprise to experience like his story
and then when you go went to visit like
rex and you got to see him again
and then got a little more background of
the whole culture behind all of and that
was what was
like that's what it's like are these
games going to stand out as much to me
playing them later on
probably not as much for you guys
because i didn't play them in the moment
when they were
kind of mind-blowing at the time and
that's one of those things for me
playing it later on
they're cool but i've played also goes
to sushi mcgoddavor has blown me away
like
certain things like that have set a bar
years ago yeah as soon as like if you
play them in context and i probably have
to go
look up be like what came out during
this time would give me better context
to know how some of these would feel
um but it like the way you got and it
all depends on how much you want to talk
to these people there is a lot of
dialogue in these games
if you keep going back and you keep
engaging yep if you
don't get into the dialogue you're
probably going to miss a lot but the way
i
when i got done because i went through
every side mission i knew all the
expansions or the dlcs i left firewalker
i left a rival which is probably fine i
heard
um speed run through this no i did
literally every loyalty mission all of
them maybe two is not long
between there's me1 actually they're
both kind of
kind of quick me3 surprisingly is the
one that i think takes the longest
to get through um but yeah it's like for
me it was
like fan was a cool standout um samara
was kind of surprising actually because
of the justica yeah the justicar
the like way they felt about her on the
asari world which i can't
remember the name of um but i'll tell
you more about the justice cars
i'd like to learn more about him
classic shepard yeah and it's like
his dialogue got a little better in this
one he does feel kind of like
canned at times because you're like
trying to learn more here and there
uh mike honestly the question will be is
if i actually like three more than all
of them
i will be wondering if that's right i
think
the consensus seems to be those new to
the series for the first time now
playing them in the legendary edition in
secession
like three uh the most and i could
understand it i could totally understand
it
yeah i was like uh i mean you get used
to it's not quite the same
here's a box room here it's not the same
room's copied over so you are kind of
traversing but it's like
here's another thing of cover that
you're going to go through and
i still went infiltrator so i did a lot
of sniping i basically clicked a bunch
of heads
um but it was cool to see um
jack was another story like having her
with you just to blow stuff so i was
like there are some
really cool characters in this world but
it was like
spend this time do like two or three
missions with this one character then
you turn and focus on the next one you
turn and focus on the next one
we went through the avengers the symbol
but now it's like now i wanna like play
three and spend
time with them because i just got to
know everybody you just got to know
about it
and then you're like okay and you're
kind of done
and it was like it was almost an abrupt
ending because i was honestly wondering
it's like i feel like you could start
go find the minimum number of crew
members and then try and finish and if
you found
enough that might work you might get
through it you probably would die i
don't know but right
um did everyone survive on your side
everybody did survive yes
nice so i had all this i had all the
ship upgrades i figured out that was
a thing uh i was playing with chad so
they kind of guided me to a couple of
the
crew choices in the final situation um
yeah it was like it was cool it was
definitely legitimate like putting
everybody together
that mission was definitely like hands
down over one there was nothing in one
that compared to
specifically like the ending mission of
that one i mean that was
that's a big distinction as you said
okay so it's like to me i don't
i mean but on the other like for mission
wise
but i will say narratively though like
the discussion with sovereign hit me
still
almost hearties yes yes most things that
happened
to powerful because that discussion with
sovereign was like
you i finally like understood how grand
of a scale we were talking about mm-hmm
um very chilling conversation yeah
basically like you don't mean squat
yeah you're kind of squashed like a bug
as well your race is inevitable
yeah talk is dope okay so sovereign was
lots of that in three
three zero three you got a lot you got
the flash of like
oh i was like all right well here they
come
so that's kind of where it's at but i
mean it's been a cool journey so far
after putting both of these together
like there's certain decisions so you
know you drive the mako around before
and you're like oh i found like here's
the resources on the ground and i did
more driving than i probably should but
i had enough resources
but i was like and now i'm like moving
my mouse around and throwing the probes
at the planet
trying to see if i get the little graph
to move i got it
and then the dlcs apparently have the
hammerhead which is the hover makeover
yeah yeah so i heard that that was
actually later because i kept bumping
into those i'm like
you guys told me there was no mako and
then i'm going through all the all these
things that was
kind of funny yeah apparently i did more
of those than i thought but
i mean overall the cast is really cool i
mean you could sit there and think about
each person
i mean the throwaways jacob kind of
feels like a throwaway his mission
wasn't
bad but his was mostly okay
all the humans are boring and yeah
they're all
kinda like miranda's was a little bit
more uh red is fun if you take
take jack on that loyalty mission you
want a good laugh
[Laughter]
jack don't give a hell about it like it
is some touching moment she's saying
real cold bloody stuff yeah
and then on the other side though it's
like when you go through and see tally's
mission
you get to see so much about and i'm
never going to get the race right what
is she
quarian quarian cool yeah there's
quarians celerians turians i'm like
why are these so close but yeah seeing
more about
her whole setup that they have and
learning more about her somebody's like
if you want a really funny time
take the last one last person that you
take the last part
and then go do that loyalty mission just
totally blow stuff i was like i can only
imagine the commentary that would happen
so there's a lot of there's some cool
stuff i mean it's
for its time economic because it's about
what 10 years old now
yes yeah it's it would be interesting in
college that's a long time
yeah so i mean obviously that was a big
one
and you know it was cool but it's like
where is it going to sit in my echelon
of games we'll see when maybe the
franchise is done i gotta see how three
goes but
i mean that's i did that took a little
break because of vacation so tried a
couple indies and having fun with those
so that was a longer discussion but i
know you guys were curious since
two giant mass effect 2 fans they're
like oh they play he played our game we
must discuss
apologies chat we just had to ask him
yeah yeah i don't know which is fine
i'm a big fan of all the mass effect
games but i i do agree
e that like if you didn't play them in
the time it's kind of weird because
i just watched my girlfriend play
through all three of them and i was sort
of like these have aged
a lot like these yeah these are look
like old games especially me1 but i mean
two
as well me3 was the one where i was like
okay i could play through this and not
like
yeah notice how old it is but yeah it's
uh
they they definitely are noticeably aged
for sure yeah yeah
so uh some stuff went down huh in this
game what what there's destiny's can we
talk about destiny now
is it time time stamps please people
please
they're like please give me the time
stamp so i can skip all your random
gaming talk yeah
i'm here for destiny only 3 33 p.m
eastern um do you guys want to start
with the crucible tweet
that's kind of the big one yes
blackburn do you want me to just read it
all and then we can
discuss the points you guys want to talk
about yeah yeah inject joseph straight
into my veins e
do it all right ahead of the showcase
this month i want to take a little time
to talk about destiny pvp everybody's
ears perked up
competitive modes are part of what make
this game special i can't imagine a
version of destiny that doesn't involve
getting a sweet new gun and taking it
for a spin on the crucible
this year the team has spent a lot of
our future facing effort on plussing up
the current crucible experience you've
seen some of this already in stasis
balancing reputation updates and
shifting
and shifting weapon metas next season
you'll continue to see this effort
not only changing to three changes to
three peaking but also is what the team
has planned for the revamp of trials of
osiris tune in on the 24th
we've got to keep our foot on the gas
when it comes to revitalizing pvp
pursuits
and keeping
with in gameplay but we know we will
we also have room to grow when it comes
to new maps and modes people
lost their mind on that sentence alone
i'm sure this first the first half of
2021 we've been working on the
foundation
but now we're spinning up teams on new
maps and modes
we believe in investment but it is going
to take some time before you start
seeing results in game
the ultimate goal here is consistency if
you play pvp
the team wants you to understand that
you will be getting new maps and modes
every year
and that cadence of those coming feels
predictable
but in order to get predictable we need
to open the faucet again
new maps take time to get right so to
open the faucet for season 16
the team is working on porting two
vaulted destiny 2 maps to be compatible
with our engine
updates when we upgraded our engine with
beyond light it means we had to hand
port all of our destiny tube maps and
modes
so while it may seem from the outside
we're just pushing a button
there's a significant amount so there's
a significant lift from the team
to get more of this content back in
rotation after reprised maps in season
16
season 17 will come with a brand new map
there are a bunch of new environments in
destiny 2
and we're excited to start bringing them
into crucible
finally after those three maps are added
and wrote in rotation in season 16 and
17
we will be remastering a destiny 1 map
and bringing it to destiny 2 for the
first time in season 18.
alder's effort is going to be done in
parallel with the team looking to fund
the far future
with a predictable roadmap of maps in
lightfall
and beyond but maps are just part of the
recipe here
we also know we need to support modes
there are three main efforts going on
behind the scenes here
first the team is investigating getting
rift in destiny 2 next year
it's been too long since we've dunked on
some guardians
the destiny sandbox has sped up in
destiny 2 so right now the team is
validating that the mode still holds up
with our new gameplay second the team is
working on multiple
brand new modes for 2022 we aren't quite
ready to spoil these yet
but we're excited to offer new twists
and rules to the ways you can make
shacks proud
finally after the death settles on the
trials update in season 15
we want to look at what other broad
systemic improvements the pvp ecosystem
needs
we want to provide something on the
scale of trials of this trial's rework
to players
every year so this twit this tweet
thread
has turned into a tweet novel but i
wanted to make sure we shed some light
on what's going on behind the scenes
here
overall we're still very interested in
growing the amount of destiny we make
every year
one way to hold me accountable by
looking one way to hold me accountable
by looking at our careers page
we're looking for environmental artists
gameplay designers lighting artists and
more to help improve our pvp output
we know you want more destiny and we're
committed to growing the team
that's going to make that possible it's
always risky to talk about what's in the
oven
as dates and specifics might change but
it's been a while
since we've talked pvp and we want
players to know that we're working on
content for those guardians
who like to spend time with shacks and
the red jacks and
i'll be here i'll i won't be here all
week
i'm just going to practice i want to try
between you
you guys are champion at the bed i
learned that's how you say i have to go
to traffic first
like there's no doubt like i would be
remiss
if that's not like the pvp thai guy
himself
attack this what's your thoughts sir
so happy
tears of joy to the joy it's what we
wanted
daddy still loves me
yeah dude this is this was great this is
such a surprise
i mean i think you know i i'm like
ironically pessimistic when i talk about
destiny a lot i think a lot of players
are but
we all know that that bungie cares about
its players and bungie
obviously cares about pvb because
they've been balancing a lot of their
sandbox around
the pvp landscape for a really long time
it's just that we didn't get
we didn't get um a lot of love
in the past almost two years and so
it's just really great to hear
specifically what their plans are and to
get
kind of like a little bit of hope um you
know
it's gonna be two and a half years
before we get a new um
crucible map it will it will have been
two and a half years so we've got like
at least six more months left which
you know isn't good but it's finally
happening
we know that they're going to be
creating new maps and that they're going
to
open the faucet to creating it regularly
which i think it
it always should have been part of what
we're getting every season and every
every year in the expansion um so i'm
grateful for that
um and then new new modes which honestly
is like the main thing like we you've
been saying
we talked about this in our and last
time we had a pvp guy on here i think it
was uh
ascend or someone um you know modes are
just what we're
we've been missing for a long time um
rift was great i don't know why they
ever took it out
give me back my twilight garrison bungie
so i can get in there and start dashing
with the warlocks
um but yeah i'm uh i'm very excited
about
about this obviously and i think uh it
came at a time where
the pvp community desperately needed it
especially since
we're not gonna get anything pvp focused
in this next season
and we're not going to get anything pvp
focused really in the in even the witch
queen which
you know the witch king queen drops and
we get one
refurbished map out of it it's going to
be a lot of people probably would think
without these statements from joe that
like they really had given it all up
because
yeah there's a lot riding on the witch
queen and if we see all of the stuff and
the pve getting a huge
overhaul um and nothing getting getting
put into pvp
obviously that's a pretty bad sign for
crucible so it's just good to know that
he explained exactly what they're facing
right
in terms of yeah having to open that
spigot and getting uh
getting um maps running again which i
think we
we really need um but let's not forget
beyond light came out we we got negative
11 maps
yeah we got 12 maps or something like
that right so we
we lost a ton of our of our maps and i
think if anything this is probably a
reversal of a decision they made
at some point in the past to not focus
on pvp
as much and i i think that was really a
intentional choice they didn't have to
take away those maps that yeah they
could they could say it was for
you know the um they destroyed all those
planets
i mean they literally told us now it's
all because of the porting
mercury's there but whatever for trials
but yeah exactly they could say it's for
it's for story reasons but i think we
both know that that that
it just isn't the case right like it was
just de-prioritized i think yeah and i
think
absolutely they sort of realized that
that was a mistake and now they're
working on fixing it but
um yeah man it's good i i think it it
helps
keep pvp has always helped keep this
game alive when pve content was
taking a lot of time in the oven and i
think it'll continue to do that
um and uh yeah this was great man
i this was this made my week thanks joe
blackburn you're awesome
what about you mixed
oh look i'm happy daddy's talking
i felt neglected i felt neglect listen
man
you know we've been abused here in this
relationship it wasn't it wasn't really
really nice you know and
look am i happy joe came out yes
you know saying this was important we
needed this we needed to know
that you know for all the monks and
months and seasons of asking
when are you going to talk about pvp
what is going on
and just the the sheer ignoring you know
just the sheer lack of transparency so
to
to get this statement was refreshing i
was happy you know
you know it's i'm of two mindsets you
know the first mindset
is they have confirmed
subtly when you mention turn the faucet
on
that means it was off at one point
yep you see what i'm saying so it
confirmed to me
that they did not i mean whether it be
again i'm not gonna be disrespectful
there's a pandemic
we understand they're doing another game
we understand i completely independent i
get it
but this was the thing that all pvp
mains know there was no reason why
there were no maps no mention of
anything you know
and and it now confirms it it was
not prioritized we were completely shut
off and they were going to
operate that way until now when they're
ready to talk about it right
so that was my little frustration with
which i got the confirmation on
you know um as to you know the the team
and holding him accountable
i like that yeah they're gonna get you
know support studio i mean not support
students but they're gonna
they're hiring right they're gonna
they're gonna get he said hold me
accountable by look at what we're doing
on the careers page
they're gonna bring this influx of
people in and stuff like that for pvp
the maps and so on and that's great you
know we want that
we still gotta wait we still got away
and i'm trying not to be negative nancy
because this is a part normally
thai guy is the guy i'm the super
positive entire guy like this like we
got a little bit of opposite
the only thing i gotta wait and see i i
need to see i
i've been hurt you know what i said so i
like it's like you know yeah i'm gonna
be better in this relationship that you
neglected y'all
you gotta prove to me like we do not
feel loved when the new expansion comes
out
we know it's gonna be a raid it's gonna
be pve content
it's gonna be this that dirt you know
what i'm getting from this
is that come witch queen
we still ain't gonna get a real new map
we're getting like a reprisal right
we're pulling something out
the vault and i don't want to again i
don't want to be disrespectful because
it's not like he said it's not you know
flip a switch
and you know boom it works the old map
works or whatever
but i do feel a way that is this
it's it's all kind of like destiny
haters
well would rip this apart like oh bro
brought back that old map again
you don't say like sure yeah like
they're gonna be like you guys are
paying for content you already had again
you know what i'm saying so it's just
like you know
you know i mean again i get it i don't
want to make this a negative thing
because this is a good thing
but at the end of the day i still need
to see a little
more and i want to see if they you know
they stick to the cadence you know
because
this is a big part of the game that's
neglected so we'll see we'll see but i'm
curious
e where you're at you know because
again we knew it it's just now i got the
confirmation i i knew
that they had not made anything there
was no priority to anything on pvp
it was completely shut down faucet was
off nobody paid the water bill that
month
i get it that's what it was but where
you at when you read all this stuff
am i going too hard on no i mean it's
been
it's been a very long time and there are
some things that are very
revealing towards the end i mean when
you talk about one way to hold me
accountable by looking at a careers page
we're looking for environmental artists
gameplay designers
they're hiring a pvp team like they're
trying to build up a pvp team this stuff
is going to take a while over the course
of
basically what i would guess is the next
18 months we're going to get
three old maps depending on how long
you've played
and then one new one over the course of
18 months
we as you said we lost 11 12 whatever
the number was so that's still a third
of
what we lost that we had before beyond
light kicked off and threw all that
stuff away
so i mean that alone this continues to
show like the destiny content vaulting
the sun setting was an idea that they
had but was executed on poorly
and whatever the plan was as you guys
said
was not not something they either
thought was going to be as much of an
issue or
just something as you guys have said the
faucet was off and they just decided to
not make it a priority
so when a question is why was it off
that i mean that's one thing
we don't know because when it comes to
like the studios obviously the
activision split was a thing
so i mean they lost vicarious visions
they lost high moon somebody in chat
literally mentioned they need studios
for help
uh and it really shows they are trying
to grow this team we have like
knowledge that they're gonna have you
know two and a half times size
headquarters that they're gonna build or
expand upon
they're working on going to be hiring
people obviously fill up that space and
do a lot more with
but also you know there were some people
like josh hamrick and other people who
left go make their own
those were some of the pvp guys there's
theoretically another ip out there
so there's pvp people that have split on
both ends it seems like
so then who was left was it the only
people who left were the pve
focus people and then that and then at
that point when you turn around and say
if this is the people we have left and
we still and they're trying to build an
engine i mean they mentioned porting
these things over to the engine is
taking them
months to do now whatever the priority
level that is we don't know how long
that actually takes
because again not a developer i get it
but of course when it turns around and
says
you know if we get four months over the
course of the next
year that's a very small number when
people have been waiting this long like
you can't
there hasn't been hardly any prep up
until this point it really sounds like
they're building pvp from scratch again
from scratch
like the live service team almost feels
like they've been limping pvp along
and then now it's like okay we're gonna
build up another destiny pvp thing
because we are probably going to be in
this franchise for longer than
either we expected or plans for
something
something happened in that studio and
and it basically was like pvp just like
you gotta we still gotta tell a story we
gotta do raids these things that sell
pve stories season pass all this other
stuff
pvp is just we don't have it and for
some reason it just was not there
and at this point they're trying to
almost start over it's
really weird to read some of the and
it's not like
it's not that i don't like seeing all of
this information i appreciate the
transparency because as you can tell
we can read a lot into this stuff shout
out to smitty smith by the way for the
two dollar shout out the last word is
the best word
i appreciate
we can get into maps and modes and stuff
like that that we've been asking for for
but the fact that it sounds like they're
almost starting pvp from scratch
yes is weird like after this long cause
i mean how much do
i know there's a vocal minority but that
vocal minority has been
asking for this stuff for a very very
very long time and while they're data
driven to maybe
say that maybe we don't need as much pvp
the you know the big stuff happens the
big money comes from eververse and
seasons and all that stuff that's going
to happen with pve either way like i
don't know what data and everything else
but it's like this is
this is one of those i would be curious
to see what happened behind the scenes
to make to get to this point
so sorry that's a very long-winded
answer yeah i i feel you i feel you both
there
to be clear um i i think your guys's
like mixed kind of take on this is
is it's it's like good and it makes
sense
my thing is that i don't i didn't feel
like i learned anything new about the
problem
of pvp from this because right correct i
i thought all pvp people kind of just
assumed that bungie clearly wasn't
working on and had de-prioritized pvp
and wasn't making maps and all that
stuff
and and so i i didn't feel like in that
regard i learned anything new i was like
well yeah of course
you guys took out 11 maps never replaced
them for over almost two years like yeah
obviously you never you were not caring
about pvp for a while so
that part wasn't new to me what was new
to me was the positive aspects because i
was sitting here assuming
pvp is never going to be a priority
again trials the season of the
of the worthy with trials was the last
thing that we're gonna get right like
after that it's just it's just pve and
then pvp will just be a side thing where
we get breadcrumbs and we
we you get to test out your uh your new
weapons there so
um i i just i'm happy to hear that that
it's not going that way and that they
are making their investments because
they could have easily not done that and
i don't think it's one of those things
i i think ibontas you might be on to
something there about
the uh the split from activision and
that sort of thing being a part of this
it could have been a resources thing
but i i think it probably wasn't
something where
bungie said in a team meeting they wrote
on a whiteboard somewhere
oh you know based on stats or based on
our bandwidth
i don't think we're going to have pvp be
a
thing that we focus on in destiny i
don't think it was an active decision
i think it was like when you never
finish a book or a video game you know
you get part way through it
and you always intend to go back to it
but it just sort of it sits for a little
bit long and then after a while you're
like okay now it's been way too long and
if i wanted to
actually finish this thing i would have
to pick up the book and start from the
beginning again you know
i think it was one of those things where
they just sort of set the book down and
they didn't pick it up for a really long
time
and then they left it too long and after
a while it's sort of like uh
you know it it's sort of you you it then
becomes
awkward to pick it back up again because
then you're like all right do i even
remember any of the characters or what
was happening in the story
um and i i think it was probably just
something like that where it was just
neglect right like
daddy neglected us cog
now now we remembered he's got kids on
the other side of town that he should
visit sometime so
[Laughter]
yeah i just don't think it's surprising
that they that they
hadn't been prioritizing pvp like
obviously they hadn't and they're
starting from scratch so i'm just not
surprised by that
what does surprise me is that they're
actually going to prioritize pvp because
i kind of just assumed they weren't
i kind of assumed that them saying like
oh yeah pvp would always be important
was just them blowing smoke
and it was because their model also
changed right now they're semi-free to
play
and i see pvp as sort of being like part
of that free part of their model it's
like oh yeah you can pay for this
premium pve content which is the stuff
we focus on
and then pvp is something that our free
users can do
and you know it's not really what we're
focused on i kind of assumed that was
the future for destiny and this seems
like they're
saying no that's not the case so you
know for me it's
it's all it's all good news because i
had assumed the worst so maybe my
pessimism helped me in this case right
cog you were you were sitting on the
porch hoping that father would come back
someday
i was off living my life going living
your life never gonna come back right
so when i saw him come back after all
and he had his cigarettes we were like
oh wow he's actually
i didn't expect to see you
you know shout out to alex and he said
he said dad went to the store and six
years later they bring back one million
gallons of milk
listen man it's true i mean you know
that's a good analogy you were you were
in that headspace and for me i was still
like
he said he was going to do you know say
like i was still in that bag i was very
emotional about like what has happened
but
you know again i can only guess my only
thing is you know
whether it be matter you know i want to
shout out the firing range guys
they had a great uh discussion about it
mercury's especially
you know when we he was talking about it
he literally said what i want to say
which is
again you know the faucet being off
being back on is the confirmation that
it was off so at the end of the day
you know i look at it and say like he
said
this is a start over right this is
literally
we're building it now now i will say
positively i do
like the trials of osiris whatever that
is whatever this
rework is that they're looking at
seriously you know i i'm liking that
i'm liking that i think if they mention
that um in the twilight we'll get to
that um say 14 is also going to mirror
like how zavala and i mean how shaq's in
the gambit are right now and
the drifter that say 14 and zavala will
mirror that structure so if they mirror
that structure
that's going to mean that just through
play and levels and ranks
you'll be able to get things right so
that's going to be interesting to see
you know like i said just sucks a little
bit the weight is going to be long but
for a person that complains about
transparency i'm at least happy
i know okay this is the intent now
now we know what daddy's
gonna do when daddy said he gonna do it
that
that that's that's that's where we at
now actually i
i guess a more apt description cog would
be that dad said he was gonna go out to
get
milk right he didn't come back for six
years and when he came back
instead of bringing a million gallons of
milk he said i'm back
and i'm still gonna bring you that milk
six months from now
six months yeah so yeah we're we're not
really getting the reveal we wanted but
uh
yeah my point is just that i couldn't
have been
less optimistic about pvp's future than
i
was so i was at rock bottom and this was
me going oh
actually i all my assumptions were wrong
they actually are going to build pvp
i just assumed that was never going to
happen so i i think my my pessimism
saved me
from a wound here which is nice yeah
this is uh my defense mechanism is just
to assume the worst in all things right
i like it i like you i do i do it we all
internalize pain
different you know that's right yeah
that's right that's right i i clam up
apparently i've learned something about
myself through all this talk
it's a reflective moment it's a
reflective moment yeah
anyway we're done talking about pvp
yeah i did want to ask you guys
something sure
kind of reading between the lines here
from all of this pvp stuff
uh i mean we got the stuff for trials we
know the cadence of the maps
we've got you know they're trying to
rebuild that's i mean you can go
as deep on that as you want to but my
question to you guys was
the number of seasons that were listed
they list season 16 which we know is
witch queen
that's the two maps that are coming back
from destiny 2.
season 17 is the one brand new map
season
18 is the one destiny one map
that's three seasons yeah every year has
four up until now do you guys think this
is actually them basically saying
they're changing their seasonal
cadence because they don't mention a
season they don't mention a season 19
and if they're planning out their year
they probably would
like before lightfall because the next
line all this effort is going to be done
in parallel with the team looking to
fund far future with predictable
roadmaps in lightfall and beyond
season 16 season 17 season 18 lightfall
there's no 19.
so i wanted to see if you guys think
that's anything
if the change in the seasonal cadence is
actually going to be coming
dots which i have i have no idea but
god i hope so dude i i hope that they do
two seasons a year honestly there should
be a spring season and a fall season
and they should focus you know the fall
season will be their main
yearly big annual release and the spring
will be some sort of like refresh
smaller story to keep us interested
and serve as a bridge to the next fall
expansion i think that's how they always
should have done it
everything else like you know age of
triumphs or whatever the heck is you
know their their
seasonal activities all these seasonal
events that they they repeat they should
just listen to some stuff that happens
in between yeah festival of the loss and
the
hero solstice and uh whatever the
the uh winter event is called uh dawning
they uh
the dawning yeah geez god there's so
many names in destiny uh
they they should just do all that as
like side stuff to keep you busy in
between these
larger releases i i've always thought
that i i think that
them them trying to do four seasons a
year makes all the seasonal content seem
so
thin and they have to artificially
stretch it out over a long period of
time
and it's often you know disappointing
all these
uh the public event at like activities
that they've been pumping out
i just haven't really enjoyed it much
i've enjoyed the story element of it but
the actual
activities of what you're doing and like
override and all this other
these things it's just it it's very much
it feels like fluff and i wish that they
would
um take a break do two big seasons where
i could play it all at once and then
you know if you don't have any content
in the summer and the uh
the winter i'll just play other games
man it's fine bunji you don't have to do
this to yourself you don't need to do
four content releases a year that's
crazy
that's crazy to me four content seasons
a year so i want them to do two that's
always been my opinion
yeah i mean said it said it best so i
mean i guess my only
thing i'll add is just that to me it all
comes down to
the content that's in the season because
we could split it up how many times we
want to split it up but if the content's
not compelling
if there's you know all these gaps i
think the thing i'm struggling right now
is
the because i'm in love with the
narrative the narrative gaps
of a cut off in mid-season and then
no further thing now all the way we had
a way to epilogue right
they were kind of you know that i i just
it still doesn't sit it's very abrupt
to me you know um it's about the content
because like you said trav like
you know i'm gonna be real like now that
i've
you know i'm override it out you know oh
god
and it's it's it's not really
challenging like
it's to the point you can low key afk
first you could look you could literally
you could straight afk like you you
between
the the sliding down you don't got to do
that you can let
one person you know shoot the thing and
go up top
you know i just that like they like even
with um
what was season of the dawn six-man
activity name now
sunday even wasn't there like a hard
sundial mode
at one point yeah like there's no there
was no challenge to i think that's why
i'm struggling with it i don't
hate it i just feel like there's no
challenge to it so
you know i'm kind of burnt out on that
and and then i'll see this season it was
you know
we didn't really get the you know the
secret mission or whatever and we get it
you know this
not every season is going to have that
and stuff like that but to me
yet it yet true yet
correct um to me it ultimately comes
down to
if they're going to split it up to the
three which is fine what's in it
you know what what the content still has
to be there to keep us
engaged and if not hey like like travis
said look
you like you've been doing it right
you've been playing the other games
you've got mass effect finish you got
my question i'm done raising at the game
but i'm just saying i just hope that if
they're going to structurally change
that it would at least the the actual
structure of it as far as the timeline
you know is not just filler kind of
stuff
that's just where i'm at but getting it
no all for me it's uh you mentioned
epilogue just kind of sparked a thought
for me
and if they're gonna have longer seasons
which
they either need to we wouldn't mind
seeing that i mean it seems like a thing
that probably needs to happen
whether it's now whether it's later they
probably need to consider longer seasons
i would not i would like to not have an
epilogue moment
i would like to go through the weeks of
the season finish
the story and not wait for this like
little
cap on the end that's like especially if
it's longer it's gonna feel worse and
worse and worse waiting to know what
that one little thing is
let us play through the weeks of the
story if you're gonna do the drip feed
for like
10 or 12 weeks whatever it's going to be
10 generally
if you're going to go that long for a
story fine ten weeks is still a very
long time to keep anybody engaged
and then you know you can have your
downtime and other stuff like that but
it's like i don't wanna be waiting for
the final piece of the story
that there's so much leaked out about
now anyway we basically know what's
going to happen even while we're gone
um i would i think that in a longer
season style it already doesn't feel
great now just being like epilogue yep
six months or six weeks five weeks
before
when are we gonna see the end of this
story that we were right here on the end
of right
so it's like if we go through and we
kill aquaria at the end of spoiler alert
sorry it's a little late but
if you go through and do all that the
next week should either finish it up or
you should do it right there and you
should like kind of see the end of the
implications of the season
because they need to tell the story in
somewhat of a confined area especially
if you're going to have
time in between i don't know i don't i
know there's going to be the drip that's
like the drip is hard anyway like for me
it feels somewhat annoying to be like
you know but people are going to blow
through it and it's their business
decision to say hey this is how we
continue
you know higher activity levels in our
game and keep people coming back every
week
there's a business decision besides why
they're not just doing an expansion
and being like here's all the story you
can blow through everything right now go
to these go to the expunge do the
like and then burn through and be done
tune in next week
yeah but at a point i don't want to tune
in next week and be like hey
you know episode 11 of 11 is gonna be
three months from now that sucks you
know what they're doing right
they literally travel appreciate this it
literally feels like
i don't know if you guys are walking
dead fans
are you what like mid-season breaks the
mid-season finale
yeah we're getting the mid season for
that yeah it's not like there's another
half a season there's like an
hour left yeah yeah yeah it's gonna take
an hour
epilogue is gonna literally take an hour
to be like whatever the thing is which
i'm trying not to say but i'm pretty
sure i know what it is
whatever story implications what little
story beat happens whatever little
cinematic
you know animated however it goes down
it's going to take like an hour and you
guys are going to be done on tuesday wow
yeah it is perfect it's that moment in
reality shows where
the guy's about to get voted off you
know voted off the cooking show and then
everybody's got that look of
anticipation on their face and then it
cuts to a commercial break
and then it comes back and then they
still don't resolve it and it goes to a
second commercial break it's like that
that same tactic of like we gotta keep
you engaged and keep you going and
i i think that's sort of their move
right like even the seasons
the fact that there's four of them is
strategic to them because it's like
keeping you invested in the story for
four times and then every one they're
selling you a season pass
every time all four times they're
selling you that season pass and i think
that's probably why we'll never get
fewer seasons because they have to sell
you four season passes instead of two
right
uh but and that's their business model
now they do a lot of microtransactions
and it's an expensive
company to run but yeah yeah i just wish
i i'm sort of like you guys like how
much money do i have to pay you
in order to just get the story now and
play like a normal video game like how
do i
how do i get
yeah it's like a mobile game where
you're like let me pay 50
just to play this without all the other
bs involved
and it's like there are sometimes you
just want to like let me play the game
at whatever pace i want to not waiting
and doing these other things it's like
how much do i have to pay to do that
i'll pay 50 bucks just to just let me do
it let me do all my stuff right now let
me enjoy it
and that's yeah there's this weird kind
of butting of heads between the
community versus them trying to run a
business
for yeah the whole data and the numbers
and stuff that they look at and that's
there's a business
choice behind some of these things that
they're doing has to be
oh i mean we've we've talked about that
for eververse for talk about that for
transmog like
they still have to make money as they're
trying to grow the studio build other
ips and other things
but there are sometimes it really butts
ahead with what the community wants
yeah yeah absolutely that's when the
business side gets in the way
yeah of the gamer real kind of thing and
you know we talked about it we talked we
talked about it with transmog we talked
about with certain little
things that we see and yeah it's clear
it's clear they're they're running it
like it's the season of the walking dead
and it's the finale
and like you said instead of it being a
whole second half of a season
notice one episode everlog okay then
done
on to the next joint and that's it then
this is the talking day we talking
we we we complain
but yeah you're talking you're doing
talking dead for 10 weeks in the middle
of when there's nothing new to talk
about
yeah you're like well we have a new we
have all the cast come through twice
even though they've already been killed
like we got travis
chris hartwick we got right now man so i
was like
yeah this is the roller coaster
that cj talked about with the dips and
the valleys and all that stuff it's just
like
seasonal water it's hard to it's hard to
talk about the game when you're
when all you're doing for 10 weeks is
playing override and and uh doing
grandmaster nightfalls and waiting for
anything and then and then you know a
series of
a thread of tweets from one of the
developers is like the highlight of the
of the year but exactly like
we had tear me and try like had tears of
joy
just even the mention of this like yeah
that's how like starving
we are for this type of pvp content but
yeah it's like it's
it's revealing to see how little to know
how little has been done in so long
to know the cadence of i would say all
we're gonna get but it's not that
of what we're going to get because it's
four maps we are getting some moats
somewhere in 2022 we are going to get
ripped it looks like it's a thing man
that's huge because that'll take the
maps that they have and give them a lot
of new life
because you'll have rift is a complete
thing that people haven't seen in
forever basically that was never in
destiny 2. yeah so they're trying to get
that one finalized plus two other modes
which we don't
know and they're not even like salvage
they say brand new so there are
i mean there's some stuff there to look
for but that's still that's six months
from now
yeah at the easiest and then whenever
those things launch that year so i mean
six months to a year
for whatever people have already been
waiting 600 you know with a joking
number for
it's it's it's not bad to see it but it
is unfortunately
ace not as much as people would hope for
and still quite
a long ways away from us away yeah so
it's like it's weird
and then but yeah it's like reading
between the line from this team pvp
man i want three teams like three yeah
that'd be cool
i'd love to see something like that no i
mean consolation prize we got some
gambit news
shout out to tassie uh yeah gambit
paul tassie i think forced the gambit
news yeah yeah
they were going to announce that so
currently we are play testing
all of uh play testing all up gambit
foundation changes for season 16
so uh that'll be witch queen focusing on
ammo economy primeval fight
invasion cadence power and more so
they're doing
foundational gamut changes for witch
queen as well so there's a team working
on that
they're not hiring for that team but
it's probably not the biggest team i'm
guessing if they're trying to do some of
that but yeah it's
it's very revealing obviously some stuff
happened a lot of big major things
happened behind the scenes to get them
to where they were
and they're trying to rebuild it sounds
like they're in like what sports teams
they're in a building year
there yeah beyond like definitely a
building year i mean shadow keep
probably was too because that was i
think post activision and
some was in the works but some was still
obviously up in the air but beyond light
obviously from what we saw was a
building here i just want yes a building
yeah agreed so does that wrap up the
there's a lot to read into that yeah
yeah um
are we done with that they said there's
a lot in this thing
uh i'm gonna kind of touch on
pieces as we go and we'll see but the
big thing is they mention
obviously read the bun the thing we just
talked about so if you want to read it
all i already got to
list it to you uh basically we got into
the next three twabs from what i've
heard multiple places i think are all
sandbox
which before i get into the sandbox
changes makes us believe what we talked
about offline
the big giant info explosion
everything's coming on the 24th is
basically where we're reading this now
right
you guys think just the 24th is now you
see yeah
now we see what's coming after just
everything right yes
yep kind of on board with that agreed
100 agree with that i think the 24th is
going to be
that's going to be the big bombshell
where we understand what the next like
18 months of destiny are going to look
like
and i think it's probably where we see
most of what
the bungie employees saw when they were
freaking out a couple months back
i think i mentioned that i still i still
think that'll happen i think we're going
to get
caught up at least to some extent to
where they were at and
if if we react like they reacted that'll
be a very good day for all of us
so so i just tweeted
you on twitter what's funny
yeah i'll send it to you there's
somebody someone dick sargent is like
i always have to wonder does travis have
suit pants on or shorts underneath the
towel
yeah what are you doing with the
bathroom shoe pants i'm in a full suit
usually so he's full dressed up and i'll
be back i'm just dressed to the nights i
see it yeah
so full tele full suit full suit yeah
is he wearing shorts or pants teddy
i
there you go no we believe you that's
true yeah he's been here he's been
he's seen me in people all right so
first thing on the sandbox is actually
not so much sandbox but
melee actions and there are some very
happy people who are excited about this
what you're basically going to be able
to do is separate
the key binds pc and probably console
you might have to find a button
but you're going to be able to separate
the key binding for your
regular melee or your charged ability
melee because there are sometimes
even if you're right next to somebody
like one millimeter away from an enemy's
face
you want to use your ability generally
because it can be more powerful
things like shoulder charges you got to
get running for but just you know
celestial fire for example whether you
do it in somebody's face as long as it's
not hurting you
you want to use it wherever and the
ability to separate those a smoke bomb
whatever it may be
if there are points where you want to
use that ability but you don't have a
way to separate
it so if you don't touch anything when
you log in everything will still work
the same this is an opt-in where you're
literally gonna have to go into the
controller settings
keyboard settings and actually choose to
have charged melee and uncharged melee
have
specific key bindings but i know there
are definitely people i've watched
streams and random enough people end up
even drewski i remember what he's like
i wish i could just i've heard people
mention this before so i think this is
just a nice quality of life thing for
control of your actions when you want to
do certain things you know guaranteed if
i click this button i get exactly what i
want
do you guys have any thoughts is that
something that's going to be beneficial
to you
are you one of those dude it's like
actually that's one of the reasons i
never use that subclass for the titan
that gives you the
uh hammer throw because yeah i just
that i don't like having to guess what
distance
i'm gonna be is gonna get me to throw
the hammer and another thing that
happens is like
if you click to throw like a hunter
knife or whatever
and you're in pve and somebody steps in
front of you you'll do the regular one
and be unable to throw your knife yeah
even if you're trying to it sort of
tries to guess based on contextual
information which one it should do and i
i kind of hate that
um yeah so this is like
badly needed in my opinion it also um
i don't think they'll do this because
it's an opt-in thing but it could give
them
the ability to create different types of
melees where
you know the uh for example the the
titan
um uh burn one where you where you
you ram into them you shoulder charge
into them and then it gives it applies a
damage
debuff or whatever so you can do more
damage to it
um that that one only works after you've
been sprinting for a while and that was
their sort of work around to get that
power and certain other powers to work
and so now that there's a separate
button for it they could actually create
new
types of melee abilities again i don't
think they'll do that because it is
optional at this point but
it opens that door to the possibility
that they could do that in the future if
they wanted to
mandate it um but yeah i i i think this
is great
awesome quality of life improvement is
it is it like life-changing no but it
certainly is going to uh help a lot of
people
i think probably especially on pc um yes
although i'll
i play on i play on console i'll
probably uh make one of the sticks
or a paddle on the back xbox already has
like a really good
um like mapping system for it's an elite
controller so i'll probably make
a paddle or something like that uh make
it so there we go
do you play or just like that cog like
is that your gaming
station where you're sitting right now
well on pc this is
this is the default this is the elite
one elite
i have the newer elite and that's in the
living room for the uh series
x got it you got it yeah but yeah you
said it best but i can't really say
anything behind
everything said it great quality of life
change cool option
you know a lot of gamers they want you
know that melee ability when
you know a thrall anything is in front
you know you want to use that power
sometimes as opposed to that the full
melee abs uh ability that doesn't do
that doesn't do the the action that
doesn't do the ability
kind of thing so yeah i think it's cool
e yeah i mean i don't there are moments
where it's been
something i was like oh i wish i didn't
do that so there
but i was like it doesn't come up as
often like it's more for like precision
pvp high level you always want to be
like exactly precise in what you're
doing but there's still even moments in
pvp
or pve stuff where i'm running through
something and i go to punch or i go to
use an ability it's not yeah
it would be nice to have the separation
i still will probably leave it auto for
a while it would probably just take me
some time to get used to it hitting an
extra key just because i'm so trained
not to
so train that so just gonna have to
break the training but i know it's yeah
it's definitely a good quality of life
across the board because it's not
required
and those who want to use it will be
able to so i think they handled it well
too
nice second piece is long-term ability
plans last season sandbox lead kevin
laid out
a hat for laid out our vision for how we
see subclass abilities fitting into the
destiny 2 sandbox moving forward
our fellow philosophy for ability design
is that ability should complement the
core combat of destiny but not nominate
it
it should enhance the game's gun play
but not replace it the changes we're
introducing in season 15 will help set
the stage for those larger systemic
ability changes in the coming seasons
we'll be focusing on adjusting how often
abilities can be used in the crucible
specifically which is good to see the
differentiation of the sandbox please
stay tuned for more info so just kind of
reiterating but
they definitely are still keeping that
as one of those things they're thinking
about you want me to grab stasis for you
since you've been talking and then
grab titan give a little break yeah yeah
man oh
general badge why is travis smiling why
did he just give me the evil sponsors
now
season 15 affiliating fast uh general
billy so looks uh they're going to be
talking about the balance changes that
are going to raise up underperforming
subclasses toned down
overpowering subclasses and here we go
without further ado so stasis
freeze the goal of these changes to make
being frozen by stasis less frustrating
previously players who were frozen in
the air had to wait until they hit the
ground and start the breakout process
additionally we're shorting the window
of vulnerability between breaking out
the stasis encasement
and losing the damage resistance it
provides and getting back to weapon
ready so you can fight back
so frozen players can now initiate
breakout while airborne shorten
breakout animation and camera transition
this means that once you decide to break
out
you'll be able to fight back sooner
differentiated long freeze and short
freeze visual treatment to make each
status
easier to identify so that is the stasis
free stuff
and then i'll just transition to um
slide and wait i guess we'll comment
after
so yeah slide the goal of the slides to
uh slide change is to slightly reduce
the effectiveness of sliding into
engagements to gain the upper hand
even after the shotgun changes we made
last season sliding into every
engagement
with a shotgun or any weapon is still
incredibly effective
and running gun playstyles are very low
risk this is a change that looks scarier
on paper than feels
in practice in our opinion and we'll
continue to monitor how it plays out
while sliding players now incur the
following
weapon penalties 20 stability
plus 15 shotgun pellet spread
and 1.5 times flinch
stasis in slide y'all what are we
thinking
not gonna affect me at all first of all
yeah first of all i use a i use a uh
a a pinpoint shotgun so my suspension is
usually affected by this
precision shotgun absolutely absolutely
usually when i'm sliding in if i'm aping
i have anteus wards on so it's not
my recoil you have to worry about it's
your own weapons accuracy
because i'm hitting you with your own
weapons so
that's that's usually my go-to move when
i run in and third of all
you know i just for me like aping is
like
okay well we we're obviously gonna win
this encounter or this
against these people so let's just like
make it quick right let's just like run
it but like
if you're in like a sweaty conversation
or a sweaty uh
match like it's not gonna you're never
it's never gonna enter your mind like oh
yeah
clearly the the move is to just like
slide in with shotguns and kill
everybody
uh if they're if they actually know what
they're doing because they'll just you
know back up and
hit you with a fusion rifle or do
something else so
um yeah i i think i think i actually
agree with what bungie said i think this
is scarier on paper than a practice
no don't get me wrong sliding around is
like
a classic uh like pro
pro tip and i think it's i think they
probably should
um make that it needs to be part of the
meta because like sliding around and
that sort of thing is still
fun um yeah but i i i tend to agree with
them i don't think the
the changes that they stated are that
big a deal and i do think it's probably
um it's probably uh
scarier on on paper than it looks on
paper than what it is let me tell you
one little
pause real quick sure
i'm just doing a little silence there
for a cut um travis can you try and talk
for a sec
yes your audio and video is like out of
sync
yeah yeah once i don't know if you want
to like activate
turn off and turn off your camera yeah
let me try that because mine sometimes
catches
how's this yes yep you're good yeah
you're good you're good you're good
you're back
i'll just do that in the future if i see
anybody in the comments uh
talking about just kind of a little bit
it's more was like twitter i literally
just was like oh let me look at twitter
and some people like
they're literally muting stuff about
sliding already slide and slide nerf
that people are not thrilled about this
they said it feels it looks scarier on
paper than it feels in practice
um somebody was like well i don't care
i'll just have my
um what is it stompies on and my icarus
hand cannon and they'll just be in the
air and it won't matter
another person i saw a joke that was
like they just want us like running and
walking only
they don't want us jumping because inner
accuracy they don't want to sliding
running and walking that's why i get
boots on the ground that's all you can
do here
twitter's gonna tweet i was gonna say is
this anything it's
i'm not as much of a slider i've seen
people use sliding very very well
and it's scary when they do because it's
damn impressive when it's used well
um the 1.5 x blitz they're going after
very specific things
shotguns snipers like they're hitting
these very specifically for
reason um i guess they don't want people
sliding around corners and hitting
head shots in crazy ways but i guess
we'll have to see how this all plays out
maybe it's not as bad as everybody
thinks
i don't know but yeah yeah i mean i am a
pretty aggressive slider anybody who see
me play crucible
just i slide a lot but i'm still i just
i just
it's not that i think them nerfing
sliding isn't a terrible idea i do
i just think the nerfs that they chose
aren't that bad yeah
yeah like yeah stability okay the pellet
spread is interesting
i mean the flintstones by that that to
me i don't i mean i don't i don't think
that's that big of a deal
i wanted to ask both of you though um
stasis
breakouts and um that whole cancer
camera transition and the whole
identification stuff like
how you guys feeling on e like where you
at with that because i know you're not
you're not team stacy so i'm curious for
just actual frozen players yeah players
yeah getting
the uh short and breakout animation all
that stuff i was curious
i mean it i like the differentiation to
know if it's like a super freeze or like
a
lesser freeze because those are
different time links so you know if you
even need to try
i think that's actually a good thing to
see hopefully a pretty substantial
distinction
like is my screen like a block of ice or
am i just like barely blue i'm like i'm
hoping it's noticeable between those two
um doing it airborne sure i mean you
can't like if you're breaking out i
guess you're trying to do it anyway
you'll probably be breaking out as you
fall
so it's a little bit faster um i mean
that's i'm not as
i'm not playing pvp as much so i'm not
really getting stasised up a lot
so that's more that's more just on what
you guys think just the differentiation
is a good thing
because if there's a difference between
how long you're frozen it's good to be
able to visually see it in quick like
quick action
mm-hmm got you um new rap makes a great
great point
he stole my idea oh yeah i think listen
i don't think it's gonna be
back to the shotgun i don't think it's
gonna be as um dominant
as people think it's gonna affect the
apes as much but i do think
it will help if they truly do something
with fusions
it could help fusions and it's a it's a
playstyle like the back pedal
the voops play style that kind of thing
to kind of cause the eggs want to close
that distance right you want to get in
there
kind of thing so i'm curious to see if
the meta shakes up
depending on the buffs that may come
with the next sandbox that's the key
because on paper
right now that sounds minimal but if
they do something else to other
archetypes
now we can see a shift and i don't know
travis here
then then it might be it might not be a
season for you
but we'll see it's early it's early we
gotta see yeah i mean i
i i just don't get worried about it
because i mean if you're if you're
committed to being good at crucible
you'll
you'll adapt and you'll figure out a new
play style and if you're if you just
want to be
like oh what you're using now and the
weapons you're using now in the subclass
you're using now are always going to be
the best most efficient way to play in
crucible like
what like why do you want that that
sounds really boring like to me
part of the reason destiny's [ __ ] yeah
part of the reason destiny's fun is
because
it's so dynamic and it's always changing
and and the meta sort of
is out in the wild and i i think
destiny's actually been best
but destiny crucible has been best when
it took the longest for
a meta to be established like a big one
so i think if they can
i i don't get scared when this sort of
stuff changes if i wanted a
game with a predictable sound sandbox
that was super well balanced
there's a lot of other games i could
play for destiny i go for the wild west
like i want it to be a little bit crazy
and for people to have
interesting weapons and you know for uh
buffs and
debuffs happening all the time and so um
yeah this is part of the game for me i'm
i'm excited to see what happens and uh
as for the breaking out of ice stuff i
think those sound like good changes
i think still obviously
stasis i think is going to get a buff
later down the road but i think right
now they're trying to
change the main complaints that we had
about stasis before they do that
and one of the main complaints is if
you're on the receiving end it just
doesn't feel good if you have
some sort of chance to fight back i
think it would have been a lot better
received and so i think they're
fixing that part and then they'll
probably end up buffing uh
stasis in pvp again i actually think
they will
like down the road but um for now the
pve buff definitely needs to happen
for for titans which they talk about so
we're going to talk about no doubt no
completely agree i think you said it
best i think i
my thought process the same that's why i
love destiny pvp
you know my whole thought the wild west
algae is perfect because
again unlike other players i don't get
in my feelings when the meta shifts
i'm already two steps ahead whenever
that shift and i see a role
of a god roll or something i think even
though it's not effective right now
this could be potentially effective if
the meta shifts
and i'll store that bad boy in the vault
so when the meta shifts
oh yeah i got that i'm ready to go so
when you stay
married to one weapon one archetype one
loadout
you're gonna be affected by these things
like what like travis said
if you play and you love destiny and you
can adapt that to me is what makes it
exciting
i actually prefer that type of style but
i know it's not easy to balance
i know it's not and i know people who
are balanced purists
hate it i get that this is not the game
for you but for me
give me the wild west who's go who's
who's the new top shooter right now
who's the new man like i love that stuff
so
it speaks to me yeah there are balanced
purists who play destiny
really yeah oh yeah people get nearly
like i don't know i mean i know i know i
know there are i'm just saying like
really guys this is the hill you're
going to die on like
destiny like worries my thing again in
my thing and then
yeah all right you know it is what it is
but yeah we got a lot of stuff titans
are up
i'm dying to hear you all on this all
right titans rally barricade
this barricade variant doesn't seem much
use um yeah
standing behind the rally big grid now
also provides the following buffs
besides the reload speed benefits 30
stability 10 range minus 50 flinch
also for barricades currently certain
fast-moving abilities allow to speed
through an enemy barricade while taking
minimal damage
the goal of this change is to make
players think twice before dashing
through a barricade to engage a titan on
the other
side barricades still can't use cause
lethal damage but
dashing through one should now leave you
with basically a sliver of health
pretty straightforward it just says
moving at high velocity you now take
more damage
uh when traveling through hostile
barricades barricades now slightly
protrude into the ground to better
protect the titan's feet on
uneven ground basically would help
projectiles and certain things from
getting
underneath the titan's barricade for
whatever reason they would
uh i mean overall rally barricade i
don't cannot think of the last time i
even thought about using it
so i mean it's a positive what's up
question
do you not use it because this is titan
talk you have to educate me
um you don't use it because y'all guys
got the new exotic that has the better
one that's sure
i don't use that that much but i mean
that's a good one for pvp anyway
for pvp you want the hype because you
need your full body coverage
even not as a pbb player there's a
reason that thing is tall
okay sightings just make sure that's
better i'm just curious because i just
throw a solo grenade on y'all so i'm
just curious how y'all
like how y'all feeling i mean that's
fine you can still shoot through it
i love to discuss i had to have to poke
the bit but for for your perspective
this is only the rally is only a pve
thing it's the only reason you never
even think about this to have
you know the reload speed the stability
of the range if you can put that if
there is a damage phase which god knows
every boss set up is like
stand here do damage if they keep that
train going
they're going to at least make rally
barricade more beneficial for some
people even in higher activities
having the reload speed now stability
extra range for certain things less
flinch like
you're going to be more on target in a
pve setting so this is going to help
that i still don't know if it's going to
help it a ton
rally barricade just seems like one of
those like not the greatest ideas in the
first place thing
oh yeah i could see it i honestly i
think
the if you can the fact that i think
it's got like a um recoil reduction or
what was the stability of 50 percent
less flinch flinch that that to me you
could snipe over that thing
i can see a lot of a lot of benefits
there but it really doesn't have any
i mean the rally barricade right now i
think is in a pretty bad place
in the meta like the hunter dodge is a
really good ability the oh that's the
best by far
the warlock well has has a lot of like
different ways you can use it and the
titans rally barricade
got nerfed in pve and nobody uses in pvp
for obvious reasons and so
you're just left with a wall and the
wall breaks really quick and if you're a
if you're let's say i've got a warlock
next to me he's gonna be dead before i
can even get the wall up because he's a
warlock
right and uh so i mean because it just
takes so long to deploy it and and then
the only the only way that you can
actually make it useful is if you use an
exotic that lets you shoot through it
which you should be able to do anyway in
my opinion with with the
with the level that the hunter and the
warlocks have with their class abilities
i think you should just be able to shoot
through the
the wall by default so uh i you know
maybe that maybe that sounds really
imbalanced maybe it is but i i just yes
it does um
but i mean it's just like the hunter
like i don't know i i guess i just have
something
yeah what is
about pve right now i know where you
going pvp i'm with you or pvp
but even 100 dogs with wormhusk okay is
a faster feel than
what is it harder than most light no i
yeah
i guess my question is it's just titan
brothers
yeah i could do no that was all oh no
i'm just saying my question i just i was
surprised that you guys
feel a little hunter ability envy
i mean i i i listen i hope he said it in
chat hunter dodge is broken with warm
husk nothing else can dodge reload heal
and get out of line of fire
at the same time hunter's using that in
pve like that though i mean you could
you literally like oh bad situation
dodge heel up
you know get out of the cover dodge to
the side like
i mean i just heard you guys look at is
powerful titan barricade
is cute at times okay
fair enough i just wanted to get the
mindset of the titan
and his barricade currently in the meta
and now again yeah
abused but other than that okay
my feeling is just that the titan
barricade is like irrelevant in the meta
more or less i mean there's
very very specific use cases you can use
it in pve
nobody uses the rally barricade in
either mode because it just got nerfed
into the ground and they never fixed it
and the tall one it's like okay well you
can't shoot through it so the only thing
it's good for is if you're
if you need to hide somewhere and wait
to heal and if you were trying to do
that you could just use a warlock well
because the war like well just heals you
right away so like what is the reason
for the titan barricade that's my
question right okay um
so i think there i think this needed to
happen i actually think it's probably
not even going to be enough i think
people
might still not use the smaller
barricade uh
in most cases and i think the tall
barricade is still just gonna be
the kind of mostly useless ability that
it is now
um so yeah i just have a uh
i i i think this is this is definitely a
picture of warlock healing well
as you said i can put up a wall i can
deflect shot shots in front of me
if anything gets outside of that little
spread
in either pve or pvp i'm still in a very
vulnerable
situation warlocks have an
omnidirectional
look wherever they want can attack or do
whatever out of a healing rift that
continues to heal
even if i use an exotic on my wall
on my barricade that heals me it's once
it's not a continuous heal you guys have
this continuous healing thing just
lasting underneath your feet you've got
exotics that make it last longer
oh yeah so i was like yeah the barricade
is definitely the redheaded stepchild of
the abilities in my opinion
compared to the other two it's probably
in i wouldn't imagine that's
behemoth uh i don't want to read the
entire wall of text here but the main
piece is cryoclassum
wild clipped bass slide now shatters
crystals and frozen enemies
uh increases the duration screen effect
effects notifying players the crowd
class long slide is ready
from one second to four and a half
seconds shiver strike they did increase
the movement speed on it by 25
because that got nerfed kind of into the
ground a little too hard and it
definitely hurt pve
and the whisper of rhyme fix the bug or
the overshield provided by whisper was
not scaling precision damage correctly
that's always one of those weird bugs
but
shiver strike increased the movement
speed it got nerfed in the ground in pve
as well which really hurt
um so that's good to see i don't know if
that's i don't know how much it got
brought down
but it's definitely not fully back to
where it was i know that right do you
know travis how much it was brought down
before
it was a lot i don't remem yeah it was
it was a significant amount but yeah
i i think this is good i mean obviously
it only affects pve so
i people tend to just use whatever they
want in pve i actually do see people use
this uh subclass in pve still i don't i
don't
yeah i haven't ever gotten much use out
of behemoth in pve it's just never
i've missed too many melees like the
tracking on it's not great that i've
missed too many enemies that i'm like oh
let me punch and slide right by
and then you have to slam and then
shatter and the warlocks over here just
like
gandalf just like a lot a lot like free
smash free smash
easy i've been watching you i've been
watching have you seen how many warlocks
do like grand masters and the
power of it's a pokemon locks are
extremely powerful
for the five seconds they stay alive
they're really good they can be
a thing to be right anyhoo middle tree
sunbreaker
camera abilities increase time before
hammer explodes
so you have instead of six and a half
seconds to pick up the hammer on the
ground it's up to ten
so if you do want to use it you can be a
little more forgiving to finish the
fight
um check and then go pick up your hammer
that also increase the damage versus
powerful pve combatants by about 50
so if you hit a you know orange or
yellow bar with the throwing hammer it's
a 50
bus buff with the front camera how are
we feeling what's up
i mean that's better it definitely
interact with the uh the separate
mapping for melee abilities too yeah
that'll and the scene will come better
yeah so because it'll it'll it'll reduce
the amount of times you accidentally
throw your hammer which happens to me
all the time like
yeah so i i i might actually give that a
subclass a spin nice i think you know
they're doing the thing they normally do
where they try to buff the less used
subclasses and hopes that people use
them more and sometimes they end up
fixing the problem and sometimes it's
not enough and nobody uses it so yeah
we'll see uh see if it's what they do
but yeah the titan ones i was sort of
like
okay like yeah that's interesting yeah i
i probably will still not use the stasis
subclass for pve
and uh but i will try out the the
solar one that that tree has always been
one i've wanted to like but it's just
never been in a good that whole
burning mall super just always feels
yeah not great
it's never felt great i was good at pvp
for a while but i think they
nerfed it i just maybe remembered the
track liking it for like two weeks i
just i don't know
but i like yeah i have to agree with you
i don't
that middle one for you off it's like oh
let's smash the ground and do this fire
tornado but it just
it's been it never feels like it's got
to travel along the ground it's the
whole thing
top and bottom tree striker some of the
game's melee base supers are a bit of a
are at a bit of a disadvantage in
today's sandbox so we've decided to give
a few of them some love
in the future we'll be looking at ways
to reduce the disparity between melee
supers and range supers in more
substantial way
i'll be curious what they do there fist
of havoc increase the slam detonation
radius by 14
uh reduce the damage fall off of slam
and then reduce the slam attack
activation cost from 21 to 18
so i guess you might be able to get one
more slam off if you do them fast
middle three striker as well uh the
inertia override which honestly i forget
what it specifically does
uh increased duration from four seconds
to six seconds sliding over an ammo
brick now grants 20
melee energy do you remember what that
does is
anything tight yeah is that the is that
the behemoth one where when you do that
uh when you do the the ground pound as
your melee ability it
charges your super maybe
like you're i'm honestly blanking on
what it is somebody in chat will
probably know faster than i do
yeah someone in chat will probably know
inertia yeah
that's what i forgot yeah that's middle
tree striker so that's like trees
exactly yeah you when you do it when you
do the when you do the pound
if you kill somebody it charges your
super so that works in pve
and pvp pbe it's super good because it
means you get your super back like all
the time especially if you
are doing a build to get your melee back
quick
because you can just keep charging your
melee and then your melee as long as
you're getting kills with that you're
charging your super
you're like money carlos yeah
it creates a it creates a cycle of you
using
just like abusing that power and just
getting your uh
your your titan slam back a bunch of
times so
i still think that's one of the most fun
trees if i'm playing in a mode and it
doesn't really matter which tree i play
as
i plays that one yeah actually usually
yeah especially with the super now just
yeah yeah top tree sentinel uh they said
ward of dawn they increased the damage
taken from bosses
from 0.25 x to 7x at zero resilience
the higher resilience uh the more damage
it can be taken now i read this is like
the player but they mentioned that down
below for
another subclass which i think it's word
of dawn they mention it on
and the way they phrased it clarified
they say same thing
uh increase the damage taken from bosses
by 0.25
for you guys that's up to one and a half
x uh the damage takens can scale based
on the
resilient stats you guys actually would
need resilience for well of radiance but
it says note
this refers to the well of radiance
itself and not the players inside the
well
so i think the same thing so if you're
standing in the well and you have your
shield you're still not going to take a
crap ton more damage by standing there
i think more it's the fact that it's the
bubble if you put the bubble on a boss
and this
boss is smashing the bubble then i think
if your resilience is not
very high then that bubble's going to
get killed quicker titans already have
high resilience so i don't know how much
this is actually going to change
but i guess they don't want people
basically spawning supers on bosses to
sit there and nuke them forever
we'll see pretty much
for hunters uh revenant main two pieces
silence and squall they increase the
movement speed
of the squall itself so the storm will
be traveling
20 faster i mean there's times you can
usually get away from it
so now we'll be chasing you with a bit
more passion uh the squall storm
now stops when it touches a bus now they
did mention it touches
when it touches a boss it stops to
hopefully make it damage more not just
kind of like roam away
run but if
they said they're working on improving
that in the future so they're trying to
figure out
how to make the super like i guess
target something and stay targeted to it
as opposed to
hit a boss stop moving then the boss
moves and then it's stuck there and
being stupid so we'll see
also withering blade projectile speed uh
they want to bring that back up a little
bit after the nerf about 10
of projectile speed and tracking will be
increased
middletree gunslinger that is uh
a thousand knives i guess knife trick
which uh increased the burning duration
from three seconds to four seconds
so they're gonna give that timer a
little bit longer
top tree gunslinger neither of us are
hunters so i'm sure there's hunters just
like screaming over all this stuff and
we're like yeah
whatever uh the six shooter damage
falloff now starts at 25 meters instead
of 20.
uh basically they just said it would
reduce how often you need to get two
shots in crucible
right it sounded like interesting
arcstrider
arc staff uh they're going to extend the
passive super duration from 16 to 20
seconds
increase the heavy slam detonation
radius by a meter
increase damage versus pde combatants by
33
so p arc staff in pve 33
stronger this is not the biggest pve
buff but there are some weak supers in
pve
yeah and we're gonna get to yours oh
yeah i can't wait which is hilarious
um how much of a but even like 33
more damage on a super again this comes
back to my like hey rockets are stuck
for two years now we're gonna give them
thirty percent
this is again when they do all the the
data and they put it all together and
they collect dollars and then they do
the research and they're testing and
we're like okay now it's a third
stronger i'm like
that's substantial yeah when you start
adding up the damage like that'll make a
difference as opposed to
hey this this doesn't feel quite right
you want to give a 10 buff
but they have to go through and do an
entire like doctoral dissertation before
they get to a final number cut off point
on the data
do you think they throw a dart at a dart
board to decide the percentage if it was
34.12
yes but 33 is kind of a number
it at least sounds good i guess uh top
tree arcstider
deadly reach increase the duration from
8 to 10 seconds
and middle tree arc strider lightning
weave dealing damage with tempest strike
now triggers lightning weave
timer can be extended by dealing damage
with any weapon i am not a hunter expert
so i'm not entirely sure what that one
implies
lightning weave um there's again hunters
sorry you're freaking out we we did not
round out the podcast with a titan award
like an honor
we are tight and heavy we apologize um
middle tree night stalker spectroblades
reduce the damage reduction
from during the super from 52 to 47
they had some of the highest damage
reduction of everybody so they're
bringing that down
and then reduce additional damage
reduction while invisible
it was a five percent increased damage
reduction now it's only a three percent
so it was 52
now it's 47 and then while invisible it
was 57 and now it's 50.
yeah so it's definitely seems to be
you'll be able to have a better chance
at killing a spectral blade if you can
spot their crazy people thank god
warlock
this one's yours yeah um winter's wrath
start with shea brander
um reduce shadow pulse damage for versus
close range
super so warlock must now freeze and
shatter twice
to defeat players in burning mall fist
of havoc
central shield novo warp arc staff or
spectral blades glacial quake still only
requires one shot
huh fair yeah i'm going i was cheesy as
hell
man getting killed out of your super
because somebody froze you and
staffed you from like 25 yards away this
to me i don't have too much of a problem
with it only because the range on it was
so
long and the fact that yeah if you have
a roaming
i mean you have a close range super you
really couldn't do anything good
yeah that that was fair now here's
there's the big one y'all
that top tree dawn yeah
deep so celestial fire that's the uh
melee so it looks like they're gonna
reduce the tracking cone angle
aiming shape proximity to the detonation
now shrinks over time
reduce detonation size by one meter
damage fall-off increased at a short
at short distances then the icarus dash
very controversial um
now provides one air dodge every four
seconds
while under the effect of heat rises
though it increases to two dodges every
five seconds
and then heat rises the increased
duration from 10 to 15
seconds increase the time extension
awarded for air kills while heat rises
is active
the extension duration differs based on
the type of enemy kill that's
interesting
your location now appears on enemy radar
when
using heat rises
this is going to be interesting in the
community
i didn't know that was the thing it did
already so i was like you're telling me
you're invisible while you're crazy
floating in the air
i didn't even know i did not know that
you know so you know
thank god this is i think this is
something that needed to happen
because that is kind of cheesy oh i'm
not being able to what about the icarus
dash and you're wonderful
yes very flying there is going to oh i'm
sorry
i'm just going to say you're already
flying you need to be invisible too it's
that bad
that's because it's that it's that it's
that uh ability to not stay alive unless
you're
if a warlock isn't hidden they're dead
right that's what happens uh
at least in my fire team i'm waiting
down wait for his foolishness to finish
so i can actually speak the facts of the
class
thank you thank you sir now that you're
foolish just in charge
like like i was saying like i would say
like i said the celestial fire is
interesting that's the melee
that part is interesting i mean i
i don't know i didn't think that part of
it the icarus dash i understand the
ignorance dash is the double that's a
lot
that's a lot of movement what is with
the snarky comet
no i'm saying like the icarus dash like
is the double did you feel that was
almost too much do you feel the one is
okay where do you because i know
seeing like a warlock do a double dash
in the air is
obviously like very powerful i wondered
where you fall on icarus dash
this is where i fall on it i think that
shout out to teddy thank you i think
travis is competing warlock
100 exactly he don't know what he talked
about but like i was saying
with the icarus dash at first when i
read it i didn't like it
right but then when i seen what they did
it's not that bad it's like one air
dodge every four seconds right now it's
probably like
you get two you know back to back you
know without anything so i don't have a
problem with that per se
where i like what people don't realize
is a low-key buff
is they're encouraging heat rises
because if you yes surprises
yeah then it increases you get two
dodges every five seconds which is kind
of
how it was pre-heat rises before you
could do the two dashes
without heat rises so basically they say
but now when you use heat rises
you're getting the the radar on the map
so that's the balance you know i'm
saying i don't i don't
have too much problem with this you know
what i'm saying but at the end of the
day i have to admit
as a warlock main in pvp
top tier that's the superior class like
it's
it's like so if they had to do something
to to bring it down a little bit in line
with the other side and we'll get into
the stuff so
overall i do hear what travis said he
just being messy for no damn reason so
we're gonna move on we're gonna move on
now this is the one i'm excited about
i'm just saying if you're if you're in
the air and you have the ability to
dodge it's already hard to see you're
not appearing on radar just sort of like
yeah all right man like how many more
advantages do you need yeah it's a bit
much it's a bit much you know what i'm
saying
but in its defense it took a long time
for top tree to get
to that level chapter used to be super
trash then they went too
far now they break it down okay middle
tree which is you know well the ratings
all that stuff okay
so the increased damage taken which he
already talked about
from boss is kind of from 0.25 x to 1.5
x
at zero resilience damage taken can
scale down
to 0.25 eggs based on the owner's
resilience that
no this refers to the well of radiance
itself and not players inside the well
which he
mentioned increased damage resistance
buff versus enemy players
from 20 to 40 interesting players inside
well of radius are now immune to stasis
freeze and slow i would have talked to e
about this
well sword can now be frozen and
shattered by stasis
and then guided in flame increased
duration from seven seconds
to ten seconds and increase damage above
from 20 percent to 25 percent
e i know me and you have in the past
have always talked about oh we joked
about fire not being able to be frozen
yes guess who gets it first warlocks oh
buff again
[Laughter]
no you got a point though you teased
that one everybody fire in the game why
are you getting frozen it doesn't sound
yeah we've jumped about
that as like you know counterbalances to
like light and dark subclasses
you have ice and you literally have fire
i'm like i'm walking around as a giant
ball of titan fire
why can't i be frozen especially from a
battlefield
especially like that would be a cool
counter play
well you're kind of getting that with
shade boundary right because if i'm
using my shades
i finally can't get frozen be like oh
i'm running yeah you've got that now
you're still gonna be able to hit me
twice and probably freeze me oh my god
you guys want everything
jesus i mean i'm just saying when when
the sandbox is finished it almost seems
natural like there should be counters
right yeah and ice and fire almost seem
like they're counting at least you know
if you hit me with an ice move
maybe the most that happens is you put
out my fire but freeze me
and then you're skipping a few steps
there you know i should just be a wet
titan
if you free hit me with the with ice and
i'm on fire you know
i should just be i should just be wet oh
i just look like i'm dripping i lose a
puddle everywhere i go
that would make sense to me i just
freezing me i just have a problem with
it i'm like you
it doesn't make sense to me but i do
think this is a good change if you're
literally standing in a well of fire
like the idea that you could be slowed
or frozen is crazy
it's kind of like i think and the fact
that it gives you guys more enemy like
the pv p buff for you guys makes well
more viable to stand in
not get frozen and obviously take less
damage so i mean you're you're going to
be really hard to kill in a while like
near impossible it seems like not near
impossible now i mean
if you thunder crash on top you may be
but i mean gun to gun standing in a well
like that damage reduction of 40 percent
plus your healing it's gonna be hard to
kill
it's hard to kill using this in the well
outside of a random
i'm not the same banner yeah i'm not
sure how well happens a lot in pvp
but i'm saying if somebody chose to use
that play style for like what about a
controller
if they commit to it if they commit to
it yes they commit to like a high
resilience
and then you know something like that so
i see people rocking at an iron banner
this week
lots of wall radiances and really
bubbles yeah really i'm used to the
bubble titan doing it i've never seen
the
but yeah i mean this would this would
definitely encourage that play style for
sure i will give e that
moving on bottom tree this one is for me
let's go phoenix
dive release reduce delay before dive
starts
can now implement a direction to dive
in that direction that's nice ignition
touch
ability rework solar ability kills and
kills on burning targets
now cause targets to explode and burn
other nearby enemies this is great this
is a play style i use
in pvp phoenix dive is supremely
underrated
because phoenix dive you can actually
heal
on the way down a snippet of your health
so you can get into an engagement
run or jump in the air and then just
come down and get a little bit of health
back
super important and the igniting touch
this is going to be good
and with dawn chorus the people to get
the buggy eye if you got that helmet
this is really going to help in pve with
burning enemies and that's one of the
highest uh dps supers
even more than um chaos reach if you're
throwing
in on somebody with the burning effect
but that's another thing anyway middle
tree storm caller
all right so now we got chaos reach
increased beam
environment collision size to better
match collision size with damage size
that's funny
reduced beam damage p radius in pvp for
20
this had to happen that that's it yeah
it's broken i have to admit as a warlock
that thing be hitting the things that
ain't supposed to hit i've i've been the
recipient of it it's it's it's messed up
reducing your whole career for sure yeah
for sure reduced
beam endpoint sphere radius and pvp by
33
i think these are all self-explanatory i
don't know if i have to go into it yeah
we know what this is this had to happen
chaos reached behind a wall i just
played a whole bunch of
um what you call a crucible recently
competitive and that was happening i was
got my nurse anyway
bottom to find that with the refunding
system and it was yeah
with the extra and teddy
teddy teddy the refund master over here
teddy
i'm gonna put on my glasses so i can do
the same thing teddy teddy 100 intellect
running chaos reach what's that what's
the name of the power when you get it to
eighty percent and you
you run and you get back yeah i know
yeah yeah topping off topping off yeah
topping off
teddy anyway that's about me i gotta
mess with him oh
i ran with him he had like four supers
in a match it was crazy yeah he's like
that every time i've done it
he's super toxic with that bill continue
oh bottom tree stone cold is the
favorite of my ark soul
increase duration from 12 seconds to 13
okay
increase fire rate by 10 percent very
underrated usually have an exotic that
does that
electrostatic surge now increases sprint
speed with allies on knee i forgot what
electro
electrostatic surge does but anyway
landfall
this is big now fire is five all
ground projectiles on cast this is good
we need that titan smash when we come
down i want a bigger
area effect that's what the titans could
do i like that for us i'm good
now this is the baby right here middle
tree void let's get it oh i saw
nobody named players oh no nem plays
so no no i can't wait to talk to them
this is for us because
ah so long increase damage by
pve versus pv competitor by 73 percent
that's insane
no that's how sad that's how much that
need it is okay
thank you anything that needs to go i
joke i'm talking about rockets needing
30
anything that needs a pve buff by 73
and somebody literally tagged me on
twitter where somebody's like uh nova
warp against the red bar
knight the red bars be laughing at you
you use nova warp
yeah that's it's a joke
that's sad like that i mean the knights
are laughing at you anyway because
you're a warlock
shut up travis what no but like that big
of a number just says
yeah that cl sub that super was broken
in pvp
or pve it was never balanced
it's like they made it for pvp and like
no one's ever going to use this in pv
but
moving on yeah no no longer slows
movement speed
no longer slows moves me while charging
in charge interesting that that we're
going to get some
mobility here that's closing distance
this could be a sleeper
and now detonates on cast
that's big so you could use it as almost
like a reaction like
boom pop it in area nova wall watch out
y'all
it could be ah e's favorite this is
favorite right here oh [ __ ] hand held
supernova this is his
baby he loves it he loves it
increased damage versus pve combatants
by a hundred percent boys
people get out of verse i don't mind i
don't mind it i don't mind it in pve
yeah that's fine it's fine but it being
the only one hit grenade in pvp is
little yeah that was messy it was it was
messy it was toxic i
yeah it was stupid it was it was dope a
lot an increased hold time though but
i guess to balance it you got to hold it
now that extra from 2.5 to 3.2
and that's it so that that's what i got
for the warlocks overall my thoughts as
a warlock mean
pretty fair i can't get too crazy i'm
really happy about nova warp i'm really
happy about um
what's called bottom tree um storm i
haven't used that in a while
and yeah i mean nova let's be honest if
you're an avoid lock
you're using devourer for the most part
and you may use top tree
to charge up so nova warp needed love i
know that guy
i know their analytics show like 0.1
percent usage because
nobody's using it i think this was i
think the warlocks got the best set of
buffs and debuffs because like you said
you're happy about these things they got
buffed and the rest of the world is
happy about chaos actually
so like chaos i think warlock's got the
most love
in all of this uh stuff yeah i thought
it was fair
what about overall what you titans like
you overall with all these things you
got
buffs debuffs like where you guys at
overall with the changes
i'm happy about barricades but i don't
think any of the subclass buffs are
really going to change a lot
i mean it's like the hammer is fine it's
you know you could toy around with a
little more if you use
but if you're stuck with the burning
mall um
nothing excites you to try e like that i
mean the top and bottom tree striker for
the slams having
you know bigger radius you know less
activation cost i mean that's not a bad
thing but i mean overall it's not gonna
none of this really says i'm gonna
change my play style
i'm not going to what are you meaning
what are you meaning pve for
end game content your go-to then
still i mean i typically i really
really should probably use my super
every so often no
usually i'm literally going through like
lost sectors i'm like i don't use my
super and i don't use exotics so anybody
who takes my guide can take my base
level crap
and use whatever you're going to use to
make it better so i don't literally ever
cast my super so it's like i just feel
like i haven't cast this
she's like i don't want to be like what
is going on
no but the reason it is
but i'm literally gonna say i'm like hey
here's a great place to cast a super hey
here's a good exotic that you can use
i'll tell you what you can
use but i don't want to be like hey
here's a champion that's kind of
annoying use your super here
but it would be my super as opposed to
anybody else's so i literally make it to
where
you know i know yeah so i make it for
everybody and then you can just take
your
build make it easier so i was like but
for me like nothing i read is
as you said nova bomb or nova warp
that's like a game changer that makes
that subclass like hey i'll go try that
out
nothing like throwing hammer for burning
maul is not enough to make me use
burning maul probably
top and bottom striker at least has some
decent potential
um but nothing it's just going to be
bigger but you already kind of smash and
blow stuff up your near anyway
middle tree striker i would have to look
what initial override does but that's
like a melee build
and top tree sentinel got kind of nerfed
so
okay honestly not much for me is really
game changing because the type
[Music]
anything exciting you like that you like
it's gonna make you at least try a new
play style a new
titan subclass oh yeah yeah i mean i'll
try all of them
uh i mean that's sort of my go-to is i
just like messing around and trying
different things which
uh people i play pvp with get mad at
because i
end up just using the session as an
experimentation and don't
get good at anything right yeah i just
like to do that i like to try different
weapons never play styles and just kind
of goof off and figure out what's good
um and then i really only ever get
sweaty toward the end of the season when
i absolutely have to um
but yeah i'll try them all out but again
i think i think the more exciting
uh buffs and debuffs are uh in the
warlock and um hunter camps
and the titans it's all sort of just
like a little bit of
fine-tuning i will say the the barricade
thing is
is big i think that's probably the
biggest thing titan's got i don't know
that it fixes it
but it will at least give us some
options and
uh less 50 less flinch if that works on
snipers and the way
i'm hoping it does um that could be a
huge game changer it could mean that
titans are just like the sniper class
now because we can just
avoid sl flinch and take people out with
our barricades and
set up shop in one part of the map and
just go crazy so um i would love that
but we'll see
we'll see what happens um so far most of
the most of the patches i mean
weirdly the thing i'm happiest about is
like the warlock
chaos reach debuff and yeah also just
the fact that i'm gonna see
more different warlock subclasses yeah
mvp is nice like just because you know
you're you're i'm facing off against
these classes too so i want there to be
variety in that
but yeah other than that just it's okay
good cool changes things up i'm overly
excited
i know you are you got a lot you got a
lot in this uh
for sure there's a shift but i mean
seeing chaos rates come down is a good
shift for others so it's like there's
there's balance both ways um as for
powering up stasis basically they state
when you get your stasis powers
getting the fragments and the aspects is
not very clearly stated to you
so they're trying to make that better
and also show the fact that it's like
a path that has like many unlocks that
you need to work through and they want
to make that very clear when you
interact with the stranger
so they are working on trying to make
the born and darkness quest
which had a lot of steps and then the
exotic and all that stuff make that much
more manageable
and they're also trying to make the
aspects and the fragments like all show
up that you don't have so you can be
like
oh i have like eight more of these
things that's going to unlock the class
so they're trying to make it much more
obvious especially for newer players if
they jump into beyond light
try it out what stasis is all about it's
this thing you should have
hey i did what did the basic quest i've
got it oh there's like 12 more things i
can work on as opposed to
is there this quest buried in my
inventory that unlocks a bunch of stuff
and they don't know it
so it's just a general quality of life
for people who aren't aware and also to
show you what you haven't got yet so
generally a good idea just makes me
wonder when we're ever going to see that
type of change for the other subclasses
but
from the they're going to do it i was
like from the pvp bandwidth type stuff i
don't see it's really soon
yeah it's gonna be awesome yeah
definitely not yeah
but other than that one thing again for
anybody listening to this i want to
reiterate
the display name of the first platform
the players log
in with des with when they play destiny
2
at the beginning of season 15 will
become your bungee
name so whatever you want that to be
pick the platform that has the right one
and make sure it's normal looking
otherwise you're going to be guardian
12722
mm-hmm that's mostly alex yes mostly it
good one good good stuff today not a lot
going on in destiny but it's still gonna
be a very
exciting couple of weeks as we see how
the sandbox shifts and get ready
for uh whatever they got planned for
august 24th
random side tangent um shout out to my
boy randolph always on last night
do you know um we know we sitting here
complaining i'm not complaining but
we'll be like yo it's not a lot to do we
did everything we had to do
whatever i'm looking at most games play
i'm like
how in the hell is destiny in the top 10
on xbox live in most gameplay
with nothing going on that goes to show
you a lot bro and i'm like
we're at the end of the sea that's what
you're supposed to check out right you
know
so it goes to show you the casuals are
still playing they still catch it up i
gotta
call my boy addict out right quick he's
catching up he's playing dusty super
casual he's catching up to the rest of
his season pass right now
finishing up so um yeah i mean it's just
it's a different time i finally got my
gm done you know got my grandmas
finally got one under my belt so i could
say i did it
and uh just working on some stuff and
that's it man but
very interesting times at least we got
some good info
you know in reference to the sandbox and
pvp and
what's going on yeah i mean
obviously the 24th just seems like more
of the bomb possible
so everything is going to be coming on
the 24th i think we were talking that
about that before we started
because the next one i literally just
tweeted to these guys because i saw dmg
said what about geomags and they said
the armor twab is next week
so geometry exotics
this is going to be probably the most
important one i think yeah
so we will see if these two want to do
it while i'm gone or if they want to
wait till we come back and do it with
our guests
definitely going to do it now okay
well then i'll just know how i love that
that's fine so yeah
that's what seems to be on deck but it
is sandbox sandbox sandbox
for the next three weeks and then on the
24th just everything else
the story the new season which we don't
know anything about that stuff's gonna
be going on jump into the new season
figure out about what's going on there
figure out the t's for which queen um i
will be gone next week
check into these two follow lord cognito
follow travis
um they will probably be tweeting where
their episode of the last word is going
to be going on for a little bonus while
i'm gone
there's a little bonus one you know yeah
and enjoy your vacation friend and enjoy
your vacation sir
thank you well as we deserve yeah as we
kind of wrap up um
we'll i'll be working on prepping and
packing and getting no sleep
um what are you guys going to be doing
over the course the next week or so any
cause we're a little earlier towards the
weekend but i mean you still might have
some stuff going and working on what you
guys got coming up
yeah i mean for me it's going to be um i
want to get that time lost fatebringer
i want to work on that because i believe
that's that's the challenge this week i
need that clan
so i'll get that done maybe just finish
up my title
and then i'll pretty much be good on
destiny at that point for a while i got
everything i need done
other than that just been uh working on
the backlog ascent came out so i want to
get that done
i have to turn my ps5 has been a while
gotta get um
final fantasy vii interlude done so i
gotta i gotta get that
just like a lot of you know cleanup
masterfuck of course you damn near past
me now and then two i gotta
get but i've been doing like every
single mission you know
been i've been like nostalgia yeah yeah
like every single one i'm doing so
i've been knocking i got the whole crew
together it's just now the loyalty
missions
and i think arrivals
but then people told me i should arrive
you should do after i heard at the end
that's what they told me they say wait
on arrival all right yeah
and that's it what about you i put mass
effect down i
beat mass effect 1 and that took a lot
out of me so i got a i got part way
through mass effect 2
and then i was like all right i just
watched my girlfriend play through all
three i need to take a break
if you've seen it yeah it's pretty fresh
yeah i literally just saw
in the entire time i was like wow i
remember way more of this game than i
wanted to
like because there's like no surprises
right
um but yeah uh i'm i'm playing
um death's door uh nice wait nice i've
got that on my list
longingly at the halo infinite uh that i
had which we played
anymore
yeah i did pretty good i got half of the
kills our team got in the
one of the few matches we got to play uh
a team of four and i think i did like
25.
all right it was on for like two hours
yeah yes yeah it was
i only got two matches in but those were
a glorious two matches
um yes yes so yeah uh it was um yeah
i've been doing that i'm working on an
ign review
for the 17th but we'll definitely have a
show before that and
other than that i've just been chilling
in destiny man i i'm i'm playing a
little bit every week i
i finished my grind for uh
solstice or uh the hero oh you did it
nice thanks i did it i got it man i
earned that t-shirt i'm definitely not
gonna wear because they refused to make
ties come on bungee
yeah um but yeah i i
i'm done with that and then uh yeah i've
got i'm
jamming an rpg this weekend so i've been
spending a lot of time uh
working on my prep work for that so
that's my life right now but
nice nice e besides vacation anything
else you're gonna play up
uh i mean yeah i was like grime i was
working through i don't know how long it
is but i mean when i come back
i need to play that one um yeah it's
like it's
that and death door are both pretty high
for me um if i can get both in before
the start of the season yeah it's like
death doors there
you need to play that [ __ ] like that one
kind of has that you know dodgy action
feel and grime is basically a
side-scrolling version
of the same thing you've got a dash
you've got progression you've got
different weapons some stats and
leveling up and kind of the souls like
combat they did a cool thing with the
parry and grime where
you parry enough and kind of absorb the
enemies and it's i don't they just
they did some cool stuff in grime that
i'm kind of digging so far for being i
think it was made by like two people
again these things where there may be
like
tiny tiny teams i'm always kind of blown
away what comes out of those so
that and then death door because i'll
come back and i'll do epilogue in like
an hour we know that's not gonna take
long so when i come back in those kind
of
two and a half weeks of downtime ish
that i'll have when i come back well
no it's like 11 days yeah i'll see how
much i get done before then yeah it's on
on the 24th so between now and then
we'll see yeah we got a lot cuz when you
come back to it's gonna be so fun too
we're gonna be hitting the ground
running it's gonna be a ton of news
yeah you guys will have to start
epilogue and armor while i'm gone
so you guys will have big stuff there
and then whatever the third one is and
we have pattycakes
uh really cool content creator streamer
uh he will be joining us on the 20th for
the basically pre-show and we'll know on
that show
on the 20th if we're going to have
anything at all to tell us what season
15 is about but i'm not holding my
breath
no doubt no shout out to everybody that
pulled up because uh again we didn't
really give much notice
this was an on-the-fly decision and it
was like 50 plus a year in there
yeah salute that that's always love to
see that uh people wanted to to hear
that 12 and you know maybe if schedules
align maybe
you know we'll see how it works today
thursdays work yeah yeah see how
thursdays work for everybody but
it's it's it's on the table we don't
know if it's that but it's on the table
but that's about all i got for this one
so thank you chad thank you everybody
for this random one you guys be safe out
there hopefully my travels are
as smooth as they possibly can be in
this crazy world but for now
a august 5th thank you guys for episode
number 161
but for this one it has been